des mandalas des étoiles ou encore d arc
en ciel
cette famille iny monteyne s'amuse à
colorier des galets plus à les cacher
dans des endroits à saint quentin en
yvelines
le gars les voyageurs se fait déjà dans
plusieurs régions le but du jeu une fois
que l'on a trouvé un galet il faut le
cacher à nouveau pour qu'ils voyagent le
plus loin possible
c'est amusant ça passe le temps et c'est
on peut s'attendre à ce que les gens ils
rigolent ils s'amusent dans le genre on
a fait un désert quand ciel des
bonhommes
on a fait des cocktails aussi est on est
on a fait en fait on a fait des mandalas
on a fait plein de trucs en fait on
s'est un peu tous plus de 90 galets ont
été cachés à guyancourt montigny le
bretonneux voisins le bretonneux et
elancourt le littoral n'a pas été
dénaturé
elles sont achetées légale et dans un
magasin de bricolage d'autres régions
font sur dans des dans des coquilles
d'huîtres vide
certaines prennent des cailloux tout
simplement le gall et nous a semblé plus
plus jolie et plus facile aussi pour
dessiner parce qu'il ya un petit peu
moins d'aspérité pour l'instant une
dizaine de galles et ont été retrouvés
et se promène dans les yvelines
mais la famille iny monteyne compte
aller plus loin on a prévu pendant les
grandes vacances d'antan menées en
bretagne dans les landes enfin là où on
ira quand on sera autorisé à bouger un
peu plus loin et on incite tout le monde
à le faire aussi pour que ça se promène
partout
en attendant les vacances d'été delphine
et ses filles ont prévu de cacher des
galets à magny les hameaux plaisir et
bois d'arcy
alors ouvrez l'oeil